HI Ladies and Gentlemen
the elements of the periodic table
There's... Hydrogen then Helium
Then Lithium, Beryllium
Boron Carbon everywhere
Nitrogen all through the air
with Oxygen so you can breathe
and Fluorine for your pretty teeth
Neon to light up the signs
Sodium for salty times
Magnesium!
Aluminium, Silicon
Phosphorus!
then Sulfur, Chlorine and Argon
Potassium!
And Calcium so you'll grow strong
Scandium!
Titanium, Vanadium, and Chromium and Manganese...
This is the Periodic Table, Noble gas is stable, Halogens and Alkali react aggressively
Each period we'll see new outer shells
While electrons are added moving to the right.
Iron is the 26th
then Cobalt, Nickel coins you get
Copper, Zinc and Galium
Germanium and Arsenic
Selenium and Bromine film, while Krypton helps light up your room,
Rubidium and Strontium, then Yttrium, Zirconium
Niobium!
Molybdenum
Technetium
Ruthenium!
Rhodium, Palladium
Silver-ware then Cadmium and Indium
Tin-Cans!
Antimony
then Tellurium and Iodine and Xenon, and then Caesium and...
*Song slows down*
Barium is 56 and this is where the table splits,
Where Lanthanides have just begun,
Lanthanum, Cerium and Praseoydmium
Neodymium's next to Promethium then 62
Samarium, Europium, Gadolinium and Terbium, Dysprosium, Holmium, Erbium, Thulium, Ytterbium, Lutetium
Hafnium, Tantalum, Tungsten and then we're on to Rhenium, Osmium and Iridium
Platinum, Gold to make you rich till you grow old
Mercury to tell you when it's really cold
Thallium!
and Lead then Bismuth for your tummy
Polonium!
Astatine will not be yummy
Radon, Francium will last a little time
Radium!
Then Actinides at 89
This is the Periodic Table, Noble gas is stable, Halogens and Alkali react aggressively,
Each Period we'll see new outer shells while Electrons are to the right
Actinium, Thorium,  Protactinium
Uranium, Neptunium, Plutonium
Americium, Curium, Berkelium, Californium, Einsteinium, Fermium, Mendelevium, Nobelium, Lawrencium, Rutherfordium, Dubnium, Seaborgium, Bohrium, Hassium, Meitnerium, Darmstadtium
Roentgenium, Copernicium
Ununtrium!
Flerovium!
Ununpentium! Livermorium!
Ununseptium! Ununoctium!
And Then We're Done!
Like the song?
Be sure to check it out on iTunes and Bandcamp
Links are in the description
and subscribe, for more awesome, weekly, science videos.